hey guys i'm ryan right and i am jerry
and alyssa uh-huh
this is Alyssa right here and tonight
we're gonna watch the most requested
video currently Batman Arkham Knight
it's not even a movie no it's not even a
show it's a video game and you play
video games I'm the biggest video game
kurd per person I'm that excited I can't
even talk I love that man Batman is the
[ __ ] III think Batman is incredibly
awesome
I saw the Dark Knight eight times in
IMAX and then I saw the Dark Knight
Rises five times in IMAX let's face it
was it as good as Dark Knight but it's
still pretty damn good you know what we
have a podcast not the three of us she
wasn't in it don't even exist we have a
podcast us two and quite back there okay
and it's called haters why we love the
Dark Knight Rises and so check it out
it's it's kind of long and for shits and
giggles I wrote a serious rap poem about
Batman what I really want out of a
Batman film is something that is like a
cross between the original like Tim
Burton version not the original that
yeah the timbre conversion and the Adam
West Virginia Tim Burton's version was
really like cartoony and then you got
the nolan version which tried going for
a lot more realism please don't say [ __ ]
about the Dark Knight Rises that is not
realistic I know some of you guys are
gonna be like would have owned his book
broke thoughts whole different wisdom
yeah people are always like Ryan was
bang all these hot girls that come on
the show and it's true we had sex right
before filming it was awesome Jerry was
walk word yeah awkward it was awkward
with Jerry there but eventually I forgot
he was there but Jerry never forgot
where he was no no I didn't know it was
mostly cuz you didn't let me get off of
the couch first at a point I was like I
want you to watch and it was pleasant
look back to Batman you guys are getting
off track err uh yeah I mean with the
video games I never I never really
played the Batman video games there was
one I played what was it Jerry
Arkham Asylum yes it was all recomment
at I played the cool game though it's
fun to be Batman but yeah everyone's
psyched about this I haven't heard this
much enthusiasm about a Batman game
until this well because Oh asylum was
peril you've got
hyped up for it maybe Alisa yeah you're
here to be hot I don't know what you're
doing disagreeing with me on camera my
show because I know my stuff you you can
rule all the trailers but you're my
don't mean now
so yeah did anybody else just get really
turned on nope
comment below and tell me if you guys
don't know so yeah I don't know what to
expect I'm hoping there's some good
graphics and [ __ ] but here we go
may contain content inappropriate for
children looks like there's a tasty
speech the last word intestine that the
deceased Thomas waiting in the event of
my death I hereby declare that all my
world is italic salary I saw except
Butchie
and Bruce
I asked you to honor the Wayne family
legacy paka which this was a movie
actress yes the improved of Gotham City
oh damn statue shows early I love the
tone of this please so dark love it I
still looks like David Boreanaz Justin
for great things make the most of your
opportunities use them to give back to a
city that has given us so much
Thomas Wayne less them is a best father
if this guy's willing to do all this
[ __ ] because of them it cannot be
frivolous with this wealth please do not
waste it all fast
oh boy that's a fast car and pursuit of
it just stuck do you look out real it
looks interesting I really really hope
this is yes we do they can make a movie
that looks just like this this money
somehow
Dali's our game like graphics cuz
they're just too good this like that
game would be so huge I will not see you
just never realize yes little is
actualized it would be awesome fast but
you never a bad thing games are getting
better you know they are with every new
version or
that's so Joey is Batmobile comes from
under the water dog I think looks like a
combination of a Batna tarantula to come
but it is the good and quick stand up
for Gotham when out do this could be a
[ __ ] movie right here
this looks like this is how they should
reboot the Batman series yeah look at
that
you look so real
to
to face and this is a Rick this is the
to face I remember
not to discredit her
yes
[ __ ]
this looks so cool
I was like you said before they've got
the fighting style that looks like how
they had it fight Ellen's movie yeah
haha
this is
I love it so excited it's like the
combination of Nolan's version in Tim
Burton's version Bateman Patrick
Jason Bateman be the Batman I will be
the Batman just for you dude that makes
you a man I haven't played a videogame
when I'm playing video games I last game
I play was Metal Gear Solid 3 that game
I play was was resistance fall of man
that was a long time ago I played bubble
breaker thingy on my iPhone all the time
anyway that looks like the [ __ ] o Lord
of [ __ ] took a [ __ ] and bam this
beautiful thing came out if I could live
in [ __ ] out of a game I went there and I
know it'd be chaotic but so beautiful no
it looks like [ __ ] it feels like you're
in the real Gotham City it looks so like
alright you wanna I wish you want yeah
it's sure you want to live in the
[ __ ] world yeah you want to live in
the world yeah yes super guy yeah it's
like that it's like you want to eat a
Batman and you want to be in this world
should make like a Batman toys or tag
course ah fit just by an abandoned
building and turn it into a Batman laser
tag you said we need a suit up yeah
neighbors won't shut the [ __ ] up
sorry ton of that movie I just imagine
like we get out of the garage and we go
through this whole extravagant thing
we're breaking down the whole Slovakia
just be the Batman of your apartment
complex this is just dress up and a mask
and a cape and jump off balconies and
tell people to be quiet after 10 a.m.
turn that music yeah you're playing the
movie doula you're late on your right
anyway guys thank you so much for
suggesting trailers please suggest more
because it you know there's always a
billion trailers and I never know which
ones to watch because it's always like
uh based off this thumbnail it might be
good more like these yeah yeah dude yeah
[ __ ] and you see this button above ELISA
says subscribe on it subscribe uh clicky
then every time we release a video
you're gonna get annoying emails from us
st. hey we got a new [ __ ] video up
what is our email counts out like that
hey I don't know hey dude hey dude we
got a new subscribe button up si hey
check out this video we could be so
racist about this let's get a taco man
also I just want to say for the record
he's wearing Batman pants that's right
you're the real Batman's underneath the
pants did you know what I mean I didn't
agree demographic is gay now wasn't he
always gay Lizzie I didn't know if he
was I'm pretty sure Ryan Reynolds played
a gay version of the green lantern not
sure if that's entirely true no I'm do
you guys not follow the comics is he
engaged the whole time subscribers will
totally agree with me on this if it
hasn't a Green Lantern or a few
different people he hasn't always been
black either no but they the one
consistent thing about all these people
is they've all been gay oh I couldn't
Jolley
hey what you're doing I get what you're
doing I'm just [ __ ] with you
yeah that's what I'm doing